why is
artemis with her deadly aim set piercing
in the heart of a hummingbird
painted
all of them
i see you there
come
closer
help me
jagged reflections from a broken mirror
behold your god
this one killed six innocent children to
satisfy her age
they squabble
burn with chelsea she
fight and murder
their cruel
victim selfish
and let the heel of achilles these
weaknesses will be
only foreign stands between me and the
rehabilitation of olympus only the
foundless most arrogant
narrow-minded cocksure son of chronos
who trapped me in his death the one and
only
zeus
oh i missed you prometheus my favorite
cousin
you chained me to this rock and fed my
liver to an eagle out of love
you need my help typhon is free
you once fought beside his allies the
titans convince him to stand down
it's not that simple
he is even blocking my ability to
glimpse the future
i cannot see past him
go on
blast me
my god
he took my lightning he took everything
even the other gods are missing
look to the mortals
that's done
those evil imbecillic tasteless
parasites were all turned to stove
one of those evil parasites is about to
save your royal ass
my ass is safely lodged in the aegean
stables and mortals will never be
anything but a mistake
care to make a wager
if i'm right my sin of stealing fire and
ensuring their survival becomes a
blessing
you'll find your punishment unjust
it's a little
extreme
do we have a deal
if you win i'll end your punishment and
set you free but if i win you help me
stop typhoon whatever it takes
very well
let the tale of phoenix be my redemption
oh no not one of your stories how long
is this going to
my tale begins at sea
a ship of soldiers returning from a far
away battle their victory ambushed by an
unexpected storm
the sea tossed and turned
waves churned to a frog
the line between sky and sea all but
vanished
the mountainous peaks of the waves
descended into valleys nearly as deep as
tartarus you're really painting a
picture here
it's an art
point is
the ship didn't stand a chance
at dawn the sun rose on the few
remaining survivors the lowest ranked
among them a shield bearer who dreamt of
battle but that scene
don't tell me
there i see her clear as day
the lowest ranked among them a shield
bearer who dreamt of battle but had seen
area skirmish
a teller of tales not a doer of these
phoenix
what a name phoenix sounds like the
sound a dumb bird makes when it lights
itself on fire which would be ridiculous
although
i should write that down
washed up on an unknown shore
phoenix awoke
look a ghost
captain
can anyone hear me
[Music]
looks like the only way off this beach
is up that cliff
[Music]
cup
phoenix saw her captain and fellow
soldiers in the distance through a trick
of the light she could almost see them
waving and calling to her
phoenix again
you may not be your brother ligiron but
i will make something of you yet hold my
shield
try not to drop it this time i didn't
see you there
don't let them get to you they're just
jealous it's not often someone has a
brother like yours
local ghosts local ghosts can you hear
me
you've gone cold
what the magic is this
lageron
where are you brother
unarmed and lost phoenix was vulnerable
i have to be calm i have to follow my
training
[Music]
so
my brother sword
no
[Music]
you've always been my hero
my north star
i will bring you back
i swear it
[Music]
phoenix had never been allowed to hold
the hallowed sword a gift from achilles
for bravery and battle
it balanced perfectly in
[Music]
is something wrong with your voice
i never got a sword
stay back
she readied her sword for her first real
fight
come into focus
i should be able to survey the land from
up there
this is the largest statue of armies
i've ever seen i wonder who built it
besieged my challenge totally alone this
young hero was determined to save her
fellow soldiers and brother boring
can we skip this path no
this is important for the sense of
atmosphere
[Music]
hermes my old friend
it's an honor to finally meet you in
person just don't tell anyone i'm
speaking to you
i got in enough trouble for memorizing
stories instead of tilling the soil back
at home and then the other soldiers
well
they really don't appreciate the good
story
uh
phoenix's destiny was becoming clear
so far all you have shown me is a mortal
soldier who has fought one real battle
and typhon grows stronger by the hour
don't toy with me prometheus
i swear to you that soldier shall be our
salvation
for if she fails and typhon defeats us
zeus king of gods the world will fall to
chaos
a temple of apollo
if it has an oracle or a seer they could
help me undo this curse
griffin
they aren't real
hey
i'll save you
i'm coming
i need to find a way to reach that rift
[Music]
how to get down
at the pond
what is this
it smells like honey and the first day
of spring
and my first kiss
all rolled into one
phoenix got into the ambrosia too
prometheus
you worried zeus about losing this bet
please she can't use it anyway
yet
[Music]
phoenix felt like eeron's blade with
every step
its weight a reminder of the heavy
responsibility you gave him your blade
oh
achilles i i meant to ask why exactly
would you expect to receive a sword from
achilles oh as an offering just a
routine offering from someone who gazed
into your eyes
and told you you were
special that's all i left a rose
on his breastplate got something in my
eye
keep going
who's done this to you prometheus stop
with the mortal bitty party and get to
the action part
fine
now that's more like
huh
shed by typhon's minions met unlike the
mortal flesh which had been frozen into
marble
the pomegranate sprung forth defiantly
bursting with life a lot of poetry for
something that just got a stick in their
mouth isn't that what the best poetry is
about
uh
hello
can you hear me in there
i'm coming
i found your axe
phoenix approached the axe
feeling it called to her
looks like the act of atalanta
must be a copy
although but before phoenix could claim
it the axe was pulled into the pit by a
terrible force
who knocks upon my door
no one
you think that all trick will work on me
come into my parlor said
well that's the end of phoenix
perfectly possible storytelling i won't
lie there were moments that dragged but
you really got me with that ending
now let's settle up
time for you to help me against typhon
it's not over yet not by a long shot
ah
what
what is this place
indeed
what was this strange place it's
tartarus
just exactly where had phoenix landed
the nasty abyss where i imprisoned
typhon he must have opened rifts into
the vaults of the underworld when he
escaped you know it i know it say it
phoenix wasn't uh sure i hate you
but aren't you intrigued no
keep going
you are either brave little one or very
foolish let's see if you can meet my
talent or if you will fall
like all the others
who are you
hello
uh
what's this
wings
phoenix ran her hands over them noticing
that several pieces were missing
as if someone had ripped them apart
they seem to be man-made
i wonder how they work
if they even work
whoa
they actually work
sort of
the axe
the axe of atalanta
deadliest of hunters swiftest of heroes
falling at the hands of typhon didn't i
change her into a lion you turned a lot
of people into a lot of things
i need to stop drinking
and now you fall
oh
you're still standing
i sense something
a bolt of my lightning
scattered hidden by typhon it's over
phoenix is helios ash no one can handle
those bolts but me
oh really
a replica of zeus is lightning bolt
no way
power surged through phoenix it was too
much for her to bear
what's happening to me bye bye mortal
and then
just like that
it stopped
no
the winds grounded the lightning
they were designed to withstand storms
that shouldn't be possible
and yet this is just the beginning
[Music]
having plunged into the abyss of
tartarus and living to tell the tale
phoenix emerged victorious
for now
that stranger i was chasing
where did he go
with the wings she would be able to flit
across the ancient bridge and find out i
wouldn't just strap on discarded junk
who knows where those have been
many a night phoenix had told tales of a
genius
an inventor named daedalus and his
extraordinary wings
perhaps someone copied their design
phoenix mused so junk
ooh
maybe it's cursed
[Applause]
what
oh
i'm coming to help hold on
if only legit was here
he's the famous hero not me
what am i going to do
put the fiends of the turtles
[Music]
yes
huh
um oregon
they're real
what's that glimmering
maybe if i sneak up on it
uh
[Music]
these bracers i've seen them in drawings
they can't be
ah but they were
heracles mightiest of mortals slayer of
beasts defied hera and accomplished the
impossible wearing those bracers
and now
they belong to phoenix through damn luck
[Music]
stop
over here
fight someone who's armed instead
so phoenix after boldly besting the
gorgon that ambushed heracles what are
you doing there that thing with your
voice
a heracles yeah that that is how it's
supposed to be pronounced seems like a
lot of work but it's your funeral except
i can't die don't remind me
by the gods
i feel like i could lift the mountain
if only those bracers
had alive you do get a room
yes
all right
[Music]
huh
uh
[Music]
hey
huh
[Music]
hey
huh
[Music]
i'm coming
how do i get in
ah
if he fell into that vault i'll save you
i promise
so let me get this straight instead of
heating up the temple of apollo to speak
with the oracle phoenix is hightailing
it after this stranger
phoenix truly a good person sought to
help the mysterious stranger but she
never lost sight of the fact that she
was getting ever closer to the temple of
apollo
and the solution to the terrible curse
inflicted upon her brother and fellow
soldiers oh yes
remind me to erase my own faults with
narration
zeus
truly a good person murdered his first
wife by getting her to turn into a fly
and then ate her wait that's what
happened to mendys
i thought she was visiting her sister in
babylon
oops huh
ah
the mark of ithaca
odysseus
[Music]
wielding power requires more than theft
footwork little one
let's see if you have control
who are you show yourself
[Music]
uh
two of the targets seemed easy enough to
hit but the third would require the
focus of a master archer forget it kids
today play seashells they skip rocks
stare at the wall you know they're
hyperactive this from the god who thinks
a week constitutes a long-term
relationship
keep that steady on little one and you
might just survive
[Music]
uh
armed with the agility of achilles the
speed of atalanta the wits of odysseus
and the strength of heracles
phoenix was ready to face whatever the
future had in store
that's it that's all she has going for
her fur good luck
i'm nearly at the oracle the desire to
save her comrades and brother hardin
phoenix's resolve ah too easy
what
huh
[Applause]
all right
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
phoenix saw the minions of typhon had
cornered the stranger leaving no escape
this would be her greatest battle yet oh
i hope the stranger dies
[Music]
it's over
you can come out
no thanks i'm good
there's nothing to worry about if i had
wanted to hurt you i could just as
easily come and stab you back there
through that
so i'm going to go
phoenix
unique name
appreciate the assistance phoenix
nice bracelets
thanks
i'm on my way to the temple of apollo to
see the oracle
me too
it's right over there
oh great
i can use all the help i can get we
should go to
where did you go
my bracers
that rotten little thief
i saved you
i know how you feel kid you do
everything you can for them and then
what's up with that who designed that
entrance a circus performer a magician i
don't know
aren't mortals wonderful
so
[Music]
huh
step forward
into the light
the mysteries i have to offer
are as infinite as the grains of sand
scattered across the flow
what is your question
oh wise oracle
how do i reverse the curse and turn
everyone back from stone
wow
that's a real that's a real question
i don't know
it's a mystery
well then
how do i get my stolen bracers back ah
another mystery
yes
that's why i came to you
the oracle oh yes well they're calling
that i'm just a priest
the oracle here turned to stone
but the smoke here is something else
the euthan sand is called sand
because it's between the sea
and the land
[Music]
uh
have you seen a little guy with golden
hair
no
i'm going to go
what's so funny
you said the goat twice
but you still haven't left
my brother was turned to stone and i
can't save him
the one person i tried to help robbed me
and all you can do is laugh
whoa
those are all true
[Music]
are you an oracle
oh oh on your way out can you pick me up
something i'm starving
father of your life
mountain
ground with flowing locks
is how you win
the monster moves hungry for immortal
flaws
the true hero owns them all stolen from
the beast's jaws
with the wind turtles
go on the attack
and sooner than later
change them all back
a barrel of seas forged fires lit
a wise child convinced
a feathers weight of which
eldest of details
father overthrown
year old high
it's time for you to come home
wow
now that was a prophecy
what was
isn't it weird how prophecy ends with i
see
but in this case i don't
stop think
you can have these bracelets back you're
going to need them where you're going
come with me
no
look i'm sorry about stealing from you
it's just something i do it's kind of a
problem
so we good
not even remotely i needed an offering
for the oracle i thought you were a
nobody and i didn't like your face but
that's all behind us now we have to go
they didn't like my
we don't have much time he will be here
soon oh
i have just a ticket for you to make it
to the mainland
where are those
wings these
now who's the thief
don't look so smug they won't fly yet
anyway you have to find the other piece
what do you mean fly
focus after that we need a jar stolen
from eggless
it's in there
i'll go begin the preparations meet me
at the top of the observatory with a jar
i
don't understand
you're in grave danger help me help you
okay but about what you said earlier
and you're gone
okay
well gotta figure out how to get past
that barrier
huh
ah
so
[Music]
uh
huh
yes
uh
what